Greek youth no strangers to showdowns
with police had reason to be angry it
was mainly young people going back to
University who were killed on February
28th when a passenger train collided
with a freight train the government
blamed it on human error and it's the
young who grew up in a recession after
the post-2008 global financial crisis
the new democracy conservatives came to
power in 2019 promising Prosperity but
the covid-19 pandemic and now High
inflation because of the Ukraine war
have largely sunk their agenda there's a
lot of job insecurity someone my age
doesn't earn enough to pay their way and
live with dignity there isn't much
opportunity it's a general situation and
people of all generations are
disillusioned with what they see as a
failing State Greece purchased automated
Warning Systems for its Railway in 2014
but still hasn't installed them
everywhere or trained everyone to use
them
they should have been monitoring off the
train on the control board whereas
visible for 5.5 kilometers after it left
the station if that had happened the
accident would have been avoided because
it would have been clear that the train
was on the wrong track rail workers
unions admit there was human error but
blame that on Greece's eight grueling
years of government spending cuts and a
botched privatization of rail operations
the government says if the safety
systems were in place we wouldn't have
had these deaths yes but why didn't we
have them all these years because we had
Personnel we had station Masters and
Technical Support we had maintenance we
hadn't left the company on a skeleton
staff working at the limit of its
ability maybe in other countries
privatization works very well but here
it hasn't
there is political opportunism here
public sector unions with grievances
against the government are riding on
this train accident to express their
dissatisfaction in this largely
left-wing opposition generated protest
however there is true Nationwide
discontent as well because the
government and the state have seemed
indifferent and dysfunctional and with
an election in fewer than five months
from now the Prime Minister and his
Entourage are nervous about how far this
reaction will ramify the government says
it'll nearly double its budget to 80
million dollars this year to improve the
rail network quickly hire more stuff and
install automated tracking signaling and
emergency braking throughout the system
but it's too late for those young people
killed here and it leaves many wondering
why it took this long for politicians to
act John saropoulos Al Jazeera Athens